[Music]
all right today's question comes from
megan in wyoming megan writes i've been
married for 14 years and due to anger
issues i need to leave my marriage and
take our children with me
i'm struggling with how to pay bills and
find a place for him to live
i'm in the first year of a great career
but my pay is not yet consistent i earn
fifty thousand dollars a year and my
husband makes about the same amount
i feel like i need to be financially
responsible for the house we own
together and an apartment for him to
move to when we separate
how should i plan financially to be
ready to leave him
um if you have come to a situation in
your marriage where you are not safe
and you decide to terminate your
marriage because somebody has made it
your home and your relationship
inhabitable you are not responsible for
finding them a place to live that's
their responsibility
yeah
this is hard man buddy of mine that does
divorce recovery many many years ago
here on the air said divorce changes a
marriage into a business transaction
this is no longer about you taking care
of him
far
from your need to take care of him
you're having to end this because he
can't control himself
so his rage and anger issues so
um
time for the mad little boy to grow up
and get his own apartment in his own
place that's right yeah
so um yeah
that feels um
like an abuse abused language exactly
what it sounds like like i need to take
care i need to make sure he's okay
to keep him calm right while i do this
big big thing yeah just so i go over
here and do all the adult stuff i need
to keep him calm that's right and uh and
or uh
i'm worried about him even i love him
even though i don't you know and that
that's all that's all abused language
right
abuse so megan you need to get yourself
a excellent attorney who will walk
things through with you you need to get
a couple of women in your life that will
walk through this with you
and
you can bounce decisions off of get a
good pastor a counselor that can walk
with you you're going to need some
support here and you trying to make sure
all the teas are crossed and eyes are
dotted including where he's going to
live and how he's going to eat and what
kind of car he's going to drive you're
taking on too much taking on too much
when someone leaves
and we you call them the ex-husband
it's because they're not the husband
anymore that's right
yeah that's why we call them x your
responsibility for how they choose to
live and eat is no more x's used to be
not anymore right your problem now over
that's what that means so it's a is a
clear line there of your responsibility
like when he walks out the door with the
suitcases that line is following him
correct and it's going to follow him as
he drives down the street like some kind
of a bad progressive commercial or
something right but
yeah and and that's okay that that's
where your line of responsibility ends
is right at his butt as he leaves so
let's take him out of the picture
mom needs to just simply circle back to
the baby steps right now she's got her
and i don't she doesn't see how many
kids let's say she's got two kids and
she makes fifty thousand dollars then
she needs to say can i afford this home
on fifty thousand dollars can i afford
the four walls bills and transportation
and food can i take care of my
necessities right as i make this this
transition and i would even go as far to
say
you need to take care of yourself if
you're not safe whether or not you can
afford that house it might mean that you
got to move to an apartment for a season
and the house gets sold that's right
yeah
so here's the last part of that that you
know that's where i was going to is
i'm going to make the number up but i'm
not far off
as i have worked over 30 years with
these situations where
there's a divorce mom wants the lady
wants to stay in the home
in this case she makes the same amount
of money usually she makes less
statistically right okay not saying
that's right or wrong this is wrong
if she does less she should make less
but if she does the same she ought to
make the same
so uh anyway she's got the same amount
of money here but the household income
is getting ready to be cut in half
i need to the kid's world is rocked
because of the marriage ending
dad's not going to be in the house the
kid's world is rocked the kid's world is
rocked and i need to provide a safe
place
stable environment for my kids i don't
want to give them any more change
than the change that's already occurring
so i don't want their school or their
friends or their bedroom to be upset so
i'm going to keep a house i can't afford
right
and i got to tell you that happens a lot
it does and instead of you getting a
fresh start after this
you're starting in the hole after this
but now it may not be the case maybe you
can afford the house it's okay but
john's advice there to where you say i'm
gonna really look at the budget and
decide can i afford on my income to keep
this house otherwise the house needs to
be sold as part of the divorce here's
what it is it's i want to prop up this
picture of family life yep and i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna cut him out of it
but i'm gonna keep this picture propped
up and you need to know when you file
for divorce everything's different yeah
that old picture is oh and those kids
are not better off in a house you can't
afford in your stress in their old
bedroom that's right than they are in a
brand new apartment that you can afford
uh and your stress level is way down and
you can be emotionally present for them
because you're not crying over the bills
after they've got a new environment can
help them actually make a psychological
shift that that now we're in a new world
that's actually helpful sometimes yeah
the visual of that's not bad that's
right yeah
so it's smart it's not always the best
thing to keep the house yeah it's not
sometimes it's okay
most of the time it's not
it's not so you're not telling you have
to sell it but i'm telling you got to
put it on the table that that's a
possibility and i'm heartbroken for you
megan yeah that's awful [ __ ] about you